America's largest motorcycle and Power
Sports trade show is right back here in
Las Vegas right but it's not just about
the toys there's some Vehicles a lot of
people are interested in right now
electric vehicles Justin Evans joining
us from trucker Power Sports at the
convention center to kind of talk a
little bit more about this um and these
cars have just become so prevalent
they're important Justin
all right yeah we're here in the Tucker
Powersports e-power booth and the EV
Market is a rapidly growing segment in
the Powersports industry and here at
Tucker we have something for the whole
family we've got anywhere from
skateboards to scooters gravel bicycles
to mountain bikes mopeds to motorcycles
and John I hear you even like go-karts
we even have a go-kart for you oh my
goodness
sign me up I'm ready I don't have to
mess with a four-stroke anymore I can
just hop on that and plug it in I don't
need it uh yeah you need to come out
come out and ride it today if you like
Justin tell us what are some of the
other trends that you're seeing in in
the power sports uh industry in the in
the community out there you know we
think so much about just you know here
in Las Vegas going out and riding out in
the dirt and in the desert but there's
so many other things that are out there
yeah with electric vehicles one thing is
they're quiet so you can ride them just
about anywhere they're not making a lot
of noise you're not going to bother a
neighborhood or an Indus you know you
can ride them just
pretty much it anywhere as long as you
follow the laws and of the roads and
regulations and make sure you always
wear the proper gear helmet
and plug it in first and plug it in make
sure yeah make sure you got to charge it
yes definitely that is priority number
one all right cool well uh thank you
very much Justin for joining us this
morning a lot of cool toys over there at
Amex one it's interesting how the
electric Market has entered something
you just assume is always right
yeah this morning